Jennifer Hudson channeled Whitney
Houston when she took the stage at Clive
Davis's pre-grammy party that's where
lizzo made her Grammy red carpet debut
with Mike Wright cardi B and offset
brought some serious PDA and Tom Hanks
and Rita Wilson made it a date night are
you and Tom getting loose tonight oh
yeah we're getting loose we'll be
dancing up there Dancing On The Ceiling
Kevin Costner was on hand to introduce
the night's host neither one of us in
the end
could protect your beloved Whitney your
fingerprints on her life are clean my
friend thank you for being her bodyguard
Clive and and at the music cares Persons
Of The Year gala where Smokey Robinson
and Barry Gordy were honored Beyonce's
Protege Chloe and Halle Bailey might
have skipped the line and already got
tickets before they go on sale today do
we have the tickets to the Renaissance
tour yet
they're watching I'm just so grateful
that we have her as a mentor and you
know we love her to death
I wanted to pop on the top risks were
taken Comfort was sacrificed I can't in
a car though the Stars shared the
inspiration behind their Styles plus
with all the craziest Grammy nights I've
ever seen only et's backstage with
Grammy host Trevor Noah and just like
that did you hear the gasps we're with a
very shocked Bonnie Raitt after she beat
Beyonce Adele Harry and Taylor I'll
never forget it I'll never forget this
moment
I brought my little classic tequila so
we're just gonna hang let me see can I
it won't fit in this tiny little bag
it's a hot sexy dress the hips are the
cleavage tonight
I unintentionally am channeling Beyonce
because she had a similar moment
Coco Jones was golden giving us B Circa
2007 as for the queen herself she wore a
metallic Gucci number complete with 70
carat diamond earrings and one of the
night's big trends Opera gloves
[Music]
[Applause]
you genuinely look like Barbie thank you
that's the vibe we're going for 70s
Barbie
[Music]
oh wait do we have a
fancy I can't sit in a car though
Doja cat also rocked gloves hers were
made to match her vinyl Versace gown
another hot Trend all black everything
how long is the train eight feet it's a
workout my legs are like
going crazy it's a little show girl a
little Glam girl a little Glam a little
kimono a little caftan
oh I have pockets what I have pockets
from Pockets to Pops of color lizzo's
bright orange Dolce and Gabbana gown had
a giant Cape embellished with flowers
and a hood girl even changed her
manicure when she changed her look Casey
Musgraves opted for pink feathers cardi
B's structured blue dress was ripped
from the runway and Kelsey ballerini was
pure sunshine I just try to look good
losing you know
Kelsey's yellow look was a nod to her
new album so was Taylor Swift's
hi Tay showed her mid-drift in a
midnight blue two-piece number by
Roberto Cavalli her current album of
course midnights
as for Taylor's X Harry Styles he wore
three different outfits this jumpsuit
had 250 thousand Swarovski Crystals fans
compared the look to the children's book
The Rainbow Fish but by far the night's
most talked about fashion let's go girls
the internet was split over Shania
Twain's pantsuit some saying it's giving
cow While others were here for it the
red hair I love the outfit I thought I'm
gonna be wearing black and white so I
wanted to pop on the top sometimes
they've been they're they're flexible
who made this jacket it's a Gucci jacket
Flo Rida was looking sharp and feeling
good especially after winning his 82
million dollar lawsuit against Celsius
energy drink what are you gonna do with
all that money I look forward to you
know taking care of the neighborhood
backstage ET cameras caught Casey
Musgraves getting last minute touch-ups
and even though he was hosting Trevor
Noah was still Fanning out I can't
believe I was part of this I'm gonna go
and I'm just gonna go and think about it
great seeing you the first lady gave us
a wave as she hit the Grammy stage for
this surprise moment and new award
recognizing a song that responds to the
social issues of our time Bonnie Raitt
beating out Beyonce Harry Adele and
Taylor for song of the year I'm flipping
out I just never expected it I mean I'm
so knocked out I'll never forget it I'll
never forget this moment
where have you been
listen before really rocks halftime only
we're in Arizona for a Super Bowl sized
stadium tour so good and speaking of
halftime someone who knows what
Rihanna's going through the queen of
Hip-Hop soul so of course I had to ask
Mary J Blige her thoughts Mary do you
have any advice for Rihanna for the
Super Bowl you just did it last year I
don't have any first of all Rihanna's
got nothing but smashes that's my girl
she know what to do I don't know if it's
so she ain't No rookie leave nothing on
the stage period and there you have it
listen she got nothing for it oh she's
like but remember Mary did that death
drop at the end of her performance last
year so give it all you got Rihanna
foreign